ah better protect your bubble calm proud
sponsors of swype on Sky News you're
watching flight on the show this week
fighting cybercrime are you being as
careful as you should be Bionic hands a
mind-controlled medical first and we've
got a real puzzler in our games review
hello and welcome to swive if you
haven't guessed already we're on the
London Eye because you never know who's
watching you or where they might be
watching from we share so much of our
lives online updating where we are and
what we're doing but with that comes
security risks and this week Angela's
been finding out how to keep your social
media safe the first thing I knew I
started getting contacts from my friends
saying why are you inviting me to become
a friend on facebook when we've been
friends for some time immediately I
suspect there's a problem one in six
adults has fallen victim to cyber crime
David Kellum is one of them fraudsters
impersonated him on social media to try
to get personal information from him and
his friends some people were fooled by
the announcement and they were talking
to the hacker on the chatline it was
quite interesting reading some of the
approaches that the hacker was taking
trying to engage these people in
money-making and opportunities luckily
nobody lost money in David's case but
the cost of cybercrime to the UK is
estimated at twenty seven billion pounds
a year users of sites like Facebook
Instagram and Twitter don't always know
how the information they make public can
be used against them by criminals or
what security steps they can take to
stop them we tell clients to make the
right friends to lock the doors and not
to advertise their whereabouts
essentially we're talking about being
streetwise in a virtual sense Facebook
is recent
nounced its own strategy to help fight
cybercrime Twitter Yahoo and Tumblr are
among the big companies collaborating
with them on the project they are
sharing information with each other
about malicious links and software or
malware and phishing attempts they hope
to stamp out security threats before
they reach users but experts say there
are some simple precautions you can take
I think the first step that they should
take to keep their content secure is
first of all to be very careful with
your password the second step is think
about the type of content that you're
putting up there and how widely you want
it to be shared and there are other
things to look out for to prevent your
account being compromised in the first
place only download apps after you've
read the reviews download that from app
stores that are known in public like
Google Apple Amazon during the public
place and you you connect your public
Wi-Fi your data is not encrypted so make
sure that you will not access sensitive
information or log into one of your
private account or social media account
also in on such a public Wi-Fi since
you've been watching this report roughly
70 hours of video has been posted onto
YouTube about 6,000 photos have been
uploaded to Flickr and around 70,000
tweets have been posted so the message
from experts is to have fun with social
media but be careful with what
information you're giving away Angela
bands Sky News well I'm joined now by
someone who knows how to analyze social
media profiles to find out a lot more
about the account holder rich Wilson
from relative insight thanks for joining
us you've been taking a look at my
twitter account have we have you found
anything interesting about me you have a
very professional persona thank you very
much taking technology determined that
you're somewhere between 35 and 39 and
probably male oh very clearly out but
there are very valid reasons for that
you post a lot of headlines and you
talk about shoots that your arm and
geography quite a lot and this this
tells us that you're you're 30 particles
not good and very professional more my
bosses are we with that and what what
can criminals or potential hackers do
with this kind of information and
there's two areas that criminals
focusing on one is masquerading so
pretending to be someone else and and
also identity theft and that varies from
small-scale credit card fraud and right
up to full-blown identity theft where
people take over accounts and mortgages
and all kinds of things and and it's all
down to the personal information that
you post online so if you're posting
where you live where you're going on
holiday potentially we've even had a
spate of people posting credit card
information online literally photos of
their new personalized credit cards wow
you think people would know better than
that wouldn't really people assume
they're talking to their friends and a
lot of social media you're talking to
the world so what yours you have to
assume that everything's going out to
the world and it's permanent it's like a
tattoo we've had some celebrities
recently get caught out some holiday
post some way that's right Ricky Hatton
a few weeks ago tweeted that he was
going on holiday and he was burgled and
so there were obvious implications for
this sorrow Cox on the other hand
recently used social media to capture
the criminals that burgled her brother's
house which she tweeted the photos of
them but Twitter I mean you could always
delete a tweet they couldn't you if you
suddenly realize it was a bit too much
information you can and that disappears
from the public realm but it stays on
Twitter servers so it's permanent it's a
pretty permanent all right rich Wilson
thanks for your top tips nice to joining
us thank you you're watching white
coming up a government operative is
dropped into a zone full of zombies
but don't worry it's just in our games
review but first is a roundup of some of
this week's other tech news a drone that
can be controlled just by using the
power of thought has been developed by
researchers from Portugal the
Netherlands and Germany a high-tech
system measures brain waves before
algorithms convert brain signals into
drone commands the researchers behind
project brain flight are optimistic that
aeroplanes could one day be piloted in
the same way and keeping with the power
of thought three Austrian men have
become the first in the world to have
their hands replaced by Bionic versions
controlled with their minds muscles and
nerves were taken from the legs and
transplanted into the forearm linking
the brain to the robotics Bionic
technology is changing lives elsewhere
this week to a blind man in America has
seen his wife for the first time in over
a decade after being fitted with a
bionic eye as part of a clinical trial
in Minnesota while there's no cure for
68 year old Alan Sarah's condition the
technology allows him to make out human
forms and basic shapes an app that
connects people around the world through
prayers has had over 30 million posts
insta prey lets users in 195 countries
share and request prayers and chat with
others in the network its founder says
he started it to create a place free of
the overwhelming negativity present
across much of the web amen to that now
it's been quite a big week for new
releases on the traditional gaming
platforms here's guy cocker with the
details okay ready anytime
first game this week is dead or alive 5
last round don't know where to begin
with this it's quite a simple fighting
game that's that combines sort of
accessibility is easy to pick up and
play with sort of technical elements you
know you've gotta time your blocks and
your and your defensive moves I can't
believe I laughs there's accurate
sweatin it's just really really gross
and I think it's a bit of a shame
because the game itself underneath is
actually quite good so dying light is
something of a unique experience in the
video games world in that it's a zombie
filled game it's an open world game so
you can either choose to follow the
storyline or go off on lots of side
quests the idea is that you're kind of a
government operative that's dropped into
a quarantine city and you're surrounded
by zombies you don't have any weapons
you have to forage and scavenge for for
weapons as you can find out whether
they've been baseball bats or pipes and
as you continue through the game you can
adapt them so you can kind of electrify
the ball it's a really interesting game
it's not doing anything that's
particularly new but I actually really
enjoyed by American overall it's worth
playing if you're a fan of something
zombie games the final game this week is
a game called Numa breath of life which
is launching exclusively on xbox one to
begin with and we'll be coming to PC
later this year it's it's in a very
unique genre in as much as it's a
first-person adventure / puzzle game we
essentially play as a god and there's no
other game like that out there that I
can I can think of looks kind of like
set in ancient Rome in a lot of ways and
it's just kind of an interesting concept
there's nothing quite like it out there
well that's it for this week but don't
forget you can stay up to date with all
the latest tech stories on Sky News for
iPad or smartphone apps guyanese calm
and our youtube channel see you again
next time bye bye ah better protect your
bubble calm proud sponsors of swype on
Sky News